ていた
[音楽]
新興国で教育に携わるために半導体で博士号が必要だと思う人
ありがとうございます
あの正直これボク必要ないと思ってるんですけどあの
先ほどの紹介にもあったようにあの今年の3月ですねうん胴体派生語詞として今社会
科学
経営状況をやってるんですけどもまぁ一見すると関係のないというか全然関係なさそう
なところでなんでそういう風に思ったのかっていうような話をできたらなと思います
この中
で学生さん程度の位いらっしゃいますよかった学生じゃない方々
じゃあ学生じゃない方々はあの僕の話を聞いてぜひ僕のキャリアについてアドバイスを
いただければなと思うのでよろしくお願いします
でへと話としてはその新興国で教育と半導体で博士号
皆さんの頭の中で多分はてなが広がっていると思うんですね
でまぁ正直僕もよく分からないというような話なので
あの大学生活をどうやって過ごすかみたいな大上段で構えたような話をするつもりは
なくてですね
ぜひこのあの私の思考とか経験を踏まえてですねアドバイスを最後あれですね質疑応答
じゃなくてアドバイスを下さればいいなと思っていますよろしくお願いします今日の
topic トピックというよりコンテンツ
ですね3つです1つ目はそのずっと僕高専出身なんですけどあの15歳からずーっと
電気をやって来て10年くらいですね10年11年から電気やってました
そんな学生があの学部時代にですねバングラデシュにインターンシップに行きました
そんな話をしたいと思いますもう一つはえーっとまあ教育にも興味があるということで
大学
時代ですねそのワークショップあの子どもたち向けのロボットワークショップだったり
とかをたくさんやったんですけれどもそこから2つの学位半導体だけじゃなくて二つ
学位を取ったんですけれどもなぜそこに行ったのかっていう話をしたいと思います最後
ですねその
助教になってからまあ社会科学系で状況になったんですけれども
あの先々週酪農家になりました麻生なんでこういうまとまりのないような一見まとまり
のないというかまぁまとまりのない話をするんですけれども
ここから皆さんがですねあの何か相手を抽出してもらって僕にこうなんですかね
フィードバックをかけてもらえればいいかなと
思っていますよろしくお願いしますまずはこの工学系の学生がそのバングラデシュに
インターンシップにいったお話をしたいと思います
多分バングラデシュというとみなさんこの画像というかこういうイメージだなと思い
ますやっぱりその人口密度がすごい高くてですね
日本の3分の2くらいの土地に1億6000万だが1億7000万人くらいいるという
ようなそんな活気のある非常に活気のあるって言っていいんですかね活気のある
ぷになりますここに僕はですねあのチッタゴンの上下水道公社というところで
インターンシップしました
8バングラディッシュ第一の都市がダッカで第2の都市が散った後ンっていうところな
んですけれどもそこの上下水道工者ですギスいって言ってもですねあのこけ水がなくて
浄水しかないですねなのでこう水を供給して
です8下水はですね川に垂れ流しという
そんな状況ですたぶん日本だと考えられないような感じかなと思います
そこで何をやったかというと例えばあの上下水や上下水ないですね
上水の施設にこうあの施設に見学に行ったりとかあのいろんなこの両下水道公社のとこ
どんどんいろんな部署にインタビューしたりとか村落分ですねそんな9分にもたくさん
人がいらっしゃってここにあの見学をしたりとか調査をしたりとかそこにある
孤児院にあの訪問したりとかで最後こういうのを3ヶ月だけだったんですけど
こういうのを全てまとめてなんかこう改善するような
プロポーザルを出しなさいというようなそんなインターンシップでした
実際にじゃあどんな問題があるかというとあのバングラの水問題というのはこのグラフ
にあの恐縮されていますでこれ
8こちらがですねあの水が欲しい量ですね
こちらが
今供給している量で僕が入った時2013年だったんですけどここですね
水の供給で30%くらいですあのーなの水道が全然普及してないんですね
日本だともうほぼだいたい100%なので皆さんどこに行っても香水動画
ひねるとあると思うんですけどまぁそういう状況でした
8まあこれからどんどんどんどん上げていこうと世界銀行とか jica の円借款と
かの授業でどんどんどんどん高
水道を普及させていくそういうようななんかあの感じでしたけれども僕が入った時には
まだまだ全然普及していない
そういうような状況ですよ一方ですね大じゃあどんな施設で水を作っているのか
っていうところをまぁちょっと見学に行きましたこれ江藤バングラデシュ散った軍の
近くに流れている川ですね
彼はからこう水を汲んでくるようなところなんですけれどもそこのポンプをとってき
ました
ちょっと見づらいですけどもすごい水がこう溢れてるんですね水が漏れてるんですね
だったりとか
バングラって電気のもんだ
水の問題だけじゃなくて電気も問題があって電気の供給量が全然足りないんですね
なのですぐ停電するんですけど定例しちゃうと水のポンプが使えないということであの
どこにも絶対に発電機があります
一方でその発電機近江あのバングラの人に聞くとこの発電機なんかよこ
案内けど20分に1回止まっちゃうんだよねという話をされました
お前電気電子のあの学生なんだからこれどうにかできるだろう
言われてどうにかできるわけがないんですけどもなんかそんな感じでいろんな問題が
ありました
で個々の問題うちはどうやって解決するのかという風に聞いた時に外注するんだ
いう話をしてましたそのバングラのその散った後上下水道公社には350人エンジニア
がいるのにその子の施設を治せる人が一人もいない
彼ら何やってるんだろういうようなそんなあの印象うけましたそこでこう
どんなプロポーザルをプロポーズしたかというとあのメンテナンスだったり
マネジメント
と建設だったりとかあと設計の現場の設計ですね
全部合わせ組んであのひとつのパッケージとして民間にやってもらう
いうような pfi 方式というのがあるんですけどこれを提案しました
でまぁあの平安してああよかったよかったっていう感じでインターンシップを破ったん
ですけど一方でこう思ったのが北電気電子の
光学工学系の出身で水なんて全然分からないですしそもそも経営系じゃないので pfi
とかあの子に行った時に初めて知ったというのはなんかそんな感じです
なので付け焼刃の知識でできることってすごい限られててやっぱりバングラのすごい
いろんな問題があるところに何かやるやってまぁ色々プレゼましたんですけど
こんなんじゃ社会って変わらないんだなというのを当たり前ですけどようやく学部の3
年生4年生が4年生の時にです
あの実感したと言う
ここからやっぱりその自分の強み専門性というのが必要だなと思って正博士語を取る
きっかけにもなりましたし
もう1つはその分析力なんか社会にいろんな問題があるけれどもそこのそもそもどの
問題から解決すればいいんだとか
どんな問題があるんだというその分析力が必要なんだなと
いうふうに思ったりしました
一方でコード仕事だけじゃなくてですねバングラの高カルチャーだったりとか人にこう
触れる機会というのがたくさんありました
冷凍2本てこうおーもーてーなしっていうような味をあるあると思うんですけど僕
バングラの方がすごい
あのホスピタリティにあふれる国だなというふうに思ったんですね
っていうのもその村落
に行為中にですバングラの田舎にこうあのアポなしで行った時に
バングラの方が寄ってきてまあ何人だって言うんですね日本人だと言うと
大日本人濃い濃い濃い濃い濃いつってあの読んでくれてその場ですぐあのご飯を作って
くれて食べさせてくれるみたいななんかそんな感じ日本だったら多分ないと思うんです
けどこういうホスピタリティに溢れた
国だなと思い出し後あれですね煌3 c が甘くてですね
あの僕にはべしがあたば合わない人もいると思うんですけどすごいご飯がを知ってで3
ヶ月がだけだったのにぼキロくらい太って帰っていくみたいな
かそういうすごいインターンシップだってなって記憶して
これ最終日の写真なんですけれどもこの
であのいろんな人によくしてもらってたんですけれども最終日すごい印象に残ってる
こともあります
この方ですねあのなんか偉い方なんですけどなんでいないのか知らないんですけど
そろそろ偉い方が日本語片言で喋るんですけど片言で言ってたことが
アジアの問題はあなたたちの問題です
あなたたちは世界を変えることができます
私は無理年だからいろんな話をしてたんですね私からおじいちゃんなんですけどすごい
人で
8それを言われたときにあのどういうことだろう
正直よくわかんなかったんですね一方で帰って日本に帰って1週間くらいして思ったの
かあそういうことっていうふうに思ったんですね
どういうことかというとそのもうバングラディシュでこういうふうに家族のように接し
てくれる人たちが周りにいてデートもうバングラとかアジアの問題ってあなたのテレビ
の向こう側の世界じゃなくてもうあなたの問題でしょ
あなたの問題を解決しなかったら多分あなたと幸せにならない
だからこの問題というのはあなたたちが解決すること
何だろうなんかたぶん拡大解釈かもしれないですけどそんな風にこう感じるあの
きっかけになりましたここからその新興国っていうのがまた2分ここか僕の原体験なの
かなというふうに思って8これこの方があの3ヶ月間ずっとフェアをしてくれた
スーパーバイザーなんですけれども
あのバングラデシュいって思ったのがやっぱりそう
専門性を身につけましょうというのとあとこういうインフラが整ってないところずっと
教育に興味があるって話をしてたんですけれども教育
このここの子ども達ってどういう環境でその教育受けてるんだろうというふうに思った
というところがあの
バングラのインターン種
経験かなと思うであの全然話は変わってですね
次に話すのはワークショップ子どもたちに向けたワークショップをして
でワークショップからあの2つ学位を取るきっかけになった
あの話をしたいと8そうですねそのずーっと工学系ノアのキャリアを積んできたので
まあそういう
感じで理系だったりと大額に進むような子どもたちをあの
まあ工学に進まなくてもいいんですけど光学こんな楽しいんだっていうのを伝えたいと
いうところでいろんなワークショップを企画しました85500人にまあ4カ国書いて
あるんですけどいろんな国であのいろんな人たちと協力しながらできてすごい
草の根レベルの活動だ
んですけどすごい楽しかったなというふうに記憶しています
レイはこういうそのコンテンツを持ってバングラに何か高級したいなと思って行ったの
が日本バングラデシュ姉妹がというプロジェクトというのをやりましたこれ何かという
とこのレゴのロボがあるんですけどこれすごい簡単で港観光へを動かすだけで
プログラミングができる
なので僕が一番ちっちゃい
ここで教えたのは2歳の子にをそのロボットを教えてまぁできたかどうかわかんないん
ですけどまぁそんな感じですごい簡単だろう
これをですね日本の中学校でえっとその時のテーマは相撲だったんですけれどもまあ
相撲の戦いをさせて優勝した
ロボットバングラに持っていってバングラでも同じ場所
そしてこう子どもたちと戦わせてそのビデオ撮ってなんかその入れ音ロボットで国際
交流をするというようななんかそんな話をしましたで一方でここで感じたのはですね
やっぱりそうやっている時はすごい
子どもたちも笑顔だし楽しそうなんですけれども
思ったのが僕がこうバングラ特にバングラにいって思ったのが
僕が最先端の技術とかパソコンとかもって言ってやったとしても僕が帰ってしまったら
これからできないじゃないかというふうに思ったんですね
これ本当に行って良かったんだっけというふうにその良いか悪いかというのわからなく
なっちゃうっていうのがありますで多分 here 子どもたちがいるんだなという
ふうに思いまそこからそう
の教育新興国教育をやるためにはまずは社会基盤を整えて
で講師のコンテンツの教育っていうところにアプローチしていく必要があるんじゃない
かというふうに思いますここからやっぱりその社会というところがちょっと僕の中でも
キーワードになってくるようになります
これがその大学院時代ででそこからですねその者介護じゃあどうやって切り取るのかと
いうところを勉強しなきゃなというところであの
技術系っていうのがあの東工大にあるんですけれども
ちょっと宣伝になっちゃいましたけど技術系の修士課程があるんですけどそれをとって
その社会の問題というのを切り取る地
っていうのを勉強しました同時にそのやっぱ社会基盤っていうのを知らなきゃいけない
というところでまぁ安藤泰で葉加瀬太郎っていうのはそんな中で得たと今年の4月から
ですね社会科学系あっ状況になりましたようなこんな感じでようやくこうなんですかね
安藤たいデート新報国っていうのが徐々に近く
言い始めてるかなというようなそんな段階かなと思います
で最後にですねその社会科学今社会科学系の状況って言ったんですけれどもこれが酪農
家になる話をして終わりにしたいと思いますねこれが実際のあれですね酪農家ですね
あのすごいんですけども朝工事なのでえっ僕ちょっと離れている所にいたので4時起き
で
8酪農家になってました営業
強気で8まあ10時半で15時半から19時まあ時間にするとちょっと短いようです
けれどもすごいやっぱりその大学教員ってすごい座っていることが多いですね
座るカモシカ授業してるかなんでこう中ロード搾乳行ったりとかあのエサやり行ったり
とか潮子を追い出したりとかするっていうのすごい重労働であの大変だなと思っ
たんですけれどもやっぱり一方ですごい高やりがいのある仕事だなというふうにも思い
ました
これなんで社会科学のアースの方研究者がこんなことをやっているかと言う話なんです
けれども
今牛プロジェクトというのが出まして何どんながやことをやっているかと言うと
ざっくり言えばですね牛にフェンサーをつけて
牛の感情だったりとか状態っていうのプラウドに上げて
でそれを後楽農家さんにフィードバックするというようなまぁざっくり言えばこういう
感じです
でこれできそうじゃんという感じなんですけど多分重要
7っていうのはそのテックその技術っていうのは技術を頑張って頑張ってこー開発し
たら
イノベーションになるんですかイノベーションって日本語でこうなんですかね
訳すとよく技術革新とか言われるので
技術を頑張って頑張って発展させればできるような気がするんですけど
たぶんそんなことなくてイノベーション
技術があっても社会に使われないと全く意味がない
むしろ社会に使われてから骨からだからこそイノベーションになるのかなというような
そんなあの日あこの社会に使われるため社会に役に立つためにはどうすればいいかと
いうとあの技術者がすっごくを開発していくんじゃなくて
現場の人と一緒にこう開発していく必要がある
現場の人を巻き込みながら研究を進めていく必要があるんじゃないかと思っていろんな
酪農家の体験をしたというような感じでその酪農家になった話あります冷凍ます碁石
可愛くてですねこれ僕の好きな菊ちゃんっていう子なんですけど
すごいかわいくてでこれへと酪農家になったのが2週間前であの先週ですね
先週ももう1回園生シニア選手じゃないか面白いか
今週も牛見に行ったんですけれどもでこのきくちゃんですねあの僕が入った時生まれて
3日目くらいだったんですけど
コーデ1週間経ってした人に会ったらすごいでかくなってですね
なんかいいな校中4買うのそのうち買いたいなと思ったんですけど
マン難しいんですけどまぁ今後穴生4買えないかなと思うと今日の話をまとめると
工学系の学生が酪農家になった話なんですけど
じゃああのタイトルに戻ると
じゃああの大事なのは酪農口からどうやって新興国のその教育につなげるのかという話
だと思います
正直これ僕はよくわかりませんなので皆さんがもしアイディアがあればぜひ僕にあの
フィードバックをかけてもらえればいいかなただその大事なのその
このブリッジの仕方わからないですけど僕が学生時代3月までに感じたのはそのゴール
を設定できた
でそこで+自分の軸を設定できた
っていうのが大事かなと思います僕のゴールはその
今今のところのゴールですけれどもその誰でもその教育にアクセスできるような
システムが作りたいというのがぐーっアプローチの仕方分たくさんあると思いますけど
僕の取ったアプローチは研究と実践を繰り返しましょう
ようなアプローチですじゃあどうするかで
軸たぶんこういう軸んだと思うんですね研究
マジッ
そしては今我々は先進国といわれる日本にいますのでまぁ先進国
そして新興国という宿になると思います酪農プロジェクト牛プロジェクトどこらへんか
なと思ったときに
あの足をプロジェクトの前ここですね僕の場合のそのゴール lifetime の
ボール
ターゲットというのはここら辺になるかなと思います
おそらくその実践珍広告の教育の現場を変えたいんだっていうような実戦になるか
牛プロジェクト多分ここらへんなんでまだまだ遠いですね
8一方でまあ家プロジェクトだけじゃなくて他にもいろんなプロジェクトしていて
例えば日本とスウェーデンのあの共同研究なんですけど食事会場ロボットの開発と普及
っていうのをやっていたりとか
起業家教育をやっていたりとかあと僕高専出身なんでそう
当選後システム教育システムを新興国に出していきましょうというようなプロジェクト
があるんですけどそこにも立つ私
ただなんかこんな感じで並べるとここに地下ついているかなって思いつつ
でもまだまだ多いんじゃないかなそんなあの
ってあのまとめるとその僕の学生時代だ
なだったかなと思うとそのドン何をやりたいのかというのを探す時間だったかなと思い
ます
研究的に言えば自分の人生のリサーチクエスチョンを多分探す時間だったかなと思い
デート学生時代ってすごい自由にできてば僕みたいにこういろんな
半導体やりながら番ぐらい行ったりとかあとワークショップしたりとか
なんかいろんなこともできるしで
8そこからその自分の原体験を探して課題自分の人生の課題
なんだこれ何がやりたいんだというのを見つけてそこに対する軸アプローチの仕方と
いうのを見つけられた時間かなと思います
一方でその学生時代にその本当に大
自分の減退金を見つけて学生時代にやりたいこともにつけてどうやってアプローチする
もいいのかっていうのも見つけられるのかと言われたら多分僕は運が良かっただけで
ですしこれからも多分あるんだろうなと思うんですけどそんなことなくて f 1番
大事なのっていうのはおそらくですけどワクワクしてたりとかなんかドキドキしてたり
とか
そういうその自分の気持ちに従いながら
をいろんなことに手つけてみるって言うのが僕大事だと思って濃淡の場合はあるさっき
一つのこと首相っていうふうにおっしゃったんですけど僕僕もそう思いますし一方で
学生時代って超自由なんで何やっても別に許され
お金もらってないですよ
なので何でも屋その自分のワクワクとかドキドキっていうのはたぶんコクーンパスって
書いたんですけどコンパスにしてあのいろいろなことをやっていくっていうのがなんか
学生時代の僕の過ごし方だったなと思いますけど皆さんはあのどういう過ごし方をする
かっていうのはぜひあのなんですかねみたいなと思いますし教えてほしい思います
発表は以上ですご清聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]